I mean looking to Stephanie beets and
being able to Oh curate music it was a
new experience to I've never been in a
studio before take it away
[Music]
felt like very inviting that they
actually acknowledged women of cuddlers
the project is called for the daughters
of Harlem working in sound and it
invites young women of color from New
York City's public schools to come to
Columbia and discuss make learn how to
record and produce their own music under
the guidance of workshop leaders because
Columbia is in Harlem I think that's why
this program is so necessary to be able
to reach out to the people of this
community for them to open up their
doors and to give us a chance that we
don't really get outside of here is
great and it makes me feel really
accepted and just comfortable and I know
the other women here can also agree
[Music]